head bowed emiram been uh Leo was led
into court charged with carrying out the
most infamous individual act of anti
Palestinian violence in recent years he
was on Monday convicted of a murder
Avraham and Saad dawabsheh and their 18
month-old son Ali by setting the house
on fire as they slept their
four-year-old son Ahmed was badly burned
but survived the trial would not bring
my family back it will not bring back
reham Saad and Ali the trial will not
bring back arm its family I don't want
there to be more children to go through
the trauma that we went through the
prosecution's had been lel along with
another youth conspired to attack
Palestinians in the occupied West Bank
after a Jewish man was shot and killed
it said the - stayed away but the 21
year old Ben Elio went himself into the
village of Duma and set fire to the de
Webster's house in their verdict the
judges acknowledged the unresolved
elements of the case in particular
witness testimony and crime scene
evidence suggesting more than one
attacker was involved but ruled that the
detailed content have been illios
confessions made it clear that he was
guilty this case attains such a high
profile and there was such pressure for
conviction that the Israeli security
services used tactics on the suspects
will normally preserved for Palestinian
detainees such as detention without
charge and enhanced interrogation
sometimes called torture when uh Leo's
lawyer says that will form the basis of
his appeal his admission and his
confession was made after serious
violation of his rights including
torture and we hope that the Supreme
Court will of the role the judgment the
Israeli security service called the
verdict a milestone in the battle
against Jewish terror but manolio was
acquitted of belonging to any terror
group the other suspect who can't be
named because of his age at the time was
however convicted on that charge as part
of an earlier plea deal this man was
convicted but we think with certainty
that he's not alone there are others out
there who were part of it and they're
free and they can still practice terror
on our people it is possible that we
would be subject to the rotala
where he attacks the New Deal is due to
be sentenced next month five years on
the dawabsheh families say they're still
far from finding a sense of resolution
Harry for said Al Jazeera Lord Israel